on the foreign policy stuff um so the
the questions that I have with regard to
to Biden on foreign policy uh very very
simple question do you think that the
situation in the Middle East is better
now than it was under Donald
Trump
um probably um that's a hard one the
factors that I'm making right now are
like obviously you've got the Israel
Palestinian War that's going on right
now which is kind of bad but like
broadly speaking I'm not sure how much
that affects the Middle East as much as
like the collapse of Syria 2013 Syrian
Civil War sent millions of immigrants
throughout all of Europe which was under
um which was under Obama and continued
under Trump trump didn't do anything to
alleviate any of the Syrian Civil War um
in ter like why did Syria end up as a
Preserve of Russia again how did Syria
end up as a Preserve of Russia yes why
did it end up being essentially a client
state of Russia um I know that Putin
enjoyed access to the ports down there
um I don't know you I mean the reason is
because Barack Obama suggested that
there was a red line that would be drawn
in the face of chemical weapons used
Bashar Assad then used chemical weapons
in Syria and Barack Obama was UN
unwilling to then essentially create
consequences for Syria in the form of
any sort of Western strike and so
instead he outsourced it to Russia this
is 2013 2014 sure do you think there
might have been some hesitancy after
like seeing how Libya ended up that
maybe us like intervening president
during Libya Obama yeah I mean like so
sure but have to do anything I'm just
saying like there might have been like a
mistake learn point I'm making is that
actually the Middle East I mean just
historically speaking was historically
good under Donald Trump I mean it's very
difficult to make decays that either
before or after Trump were better than
during Donald Trump the Syrian I don't
think that that Trump contributed to the
Syrian situation improving much um I
think he wreck Isis which was in the I
mean Isis had been getting wrecked by
the Kurds in Iraq by every single person
by Assad's Army by Putin by turkey
literally everybody was fighting against
Isis at that point there there's a spike
in violence then the the Trump I mean
you get credit for when you're president
presumably I mean things got better with
Isis under Trump I mean yeah they did I
mean things got worse with Isis under
Obama they for sure he called them the
JV Squad and then they became not the JV
Squad yeah but I don't know Isis is
originating in Syria um and uh Baghdad
and all of the growth of that is
necessarily Obama's fault I know that we
like to say that Obama created Isis I
don't know if you say that but I've
heard that saying a lot I think that's a
little bit simplistic um I I don't think
that when I'm looking at like actions
that presidents have taken the the big
the biggest criticism I have for like
Middle Eastern policy is I think the
Doha Accords were a disaster and I think
that's like one of the biggest blemishes
that we have right now I would also
argue that moving the um Embassy to
Jerusalem was also kind of silly um and
arguably contributed to some of the
conflict we see right now I'll argue
precisely the opposite especially given
the fact that after the movement of the
embassy to Jerusalem the Abraham Accords
continued to sign and actually expand
and that if Donald Trump had been
elected I have no doubt in my mind that
Saudi Arabia would now be a part of the
Abraham Accords in fact that was
basically pre-negotiated and then when
Joe Biden took office Joe Biden took a
very anti-saudi stance on a wide variety
of issues the the biggest single effect
in the Middle East of Joe Biden's
presidency and again I agree with you
that not every foreign policy issue can
be laid at the hands of a President Joe
Biden's main approach to the Middle East
was very similar to the Obama approach
which is why the Middle East was chaotic
under Obama and chaotic under Biden and
that was to alienate allies like Saudi
Arabia and Israel and instead to try to
make common cause or cut deals with Iran
what that did is incentivize terrorism
from Iran what we're watching in the
Middle East is Iran attempting to use
every one of its Terror proxies in the
Middle East and it was specifically
launched in an attempt to avoid what
Biden actually was trying to do which
was good which was after two years of
failure with Saudi Arabia try to bring
them into the Abraham Accords right that
was what was burgeoning at the end of La
at the end of last year and Iran saw
that and Iran decided that they were
going to throw grenade into the middle
of those negotiations by essentially
activating Hamas Hamas activates Hamas
commits October 7th Israel as a
Sovereign Nation state has to respond to
the murder of 1200 of its citizens and
the taken kidnapping of of 240 Israel
has to do that not only to go after its
own hostages and try to restore them but
also to reestablish military deterrence
in the most violent region of the world
kisah gets active on Israel's northern
border kisah is an Iranian proxy they
get active on the northern border the
the hthis in Yemen get active these are
all the only reason all this is
happening at the same time is because
Iran is doing this right not just that
they're they are threatening global
Shipping if you're talking about the
effects of global supply lines which I
toally agree had a major inflationary
effect on the economy thanks to right
now the cost of shipping is nearly
double what it was just a few weeks ago
and that is because a ragtag group of
hthi Barbarians are attacking
international shipping and forcing
everybody to stop using the Babel M
Freight instead going around the Cape of
Good Hope in in Africa all of that is
the result of the fact that Joe Biden
reoriented the United States in the very
early days in favor of a more Pro
Iranian stance he appointed Robert Mali
to negotiate the Iran deal who as it
turns out was using
many of his AIDS were actually taking
money from Iran the the the Biden
Administration literally one of their
first acts was to delist the hoodies as
a terror organization and sanctions
against the hoodies these are all moves
that that Biden made very early on they
were disastrous moves but when it comes
to domestic policy I think he hasn't
been nearly as dam domastic fore sure
sure so just on a couple Middle Eastern
things so one of the big things that
threw the Middle East into disaster was
we are all traumatized by it now was the
Iraq invasion which I'm a Republican
president sure agre that right the
the deposition of Saddam Hussein and
everything that followed after probably
contributed more to the growth of Isis
and the destabilization of that entire
region probably more than anything else
I think that under prior to Bush um for
Clinton and even at the beginning of
Bush's presidency we were on some kind
of road to normaly um with Iran which I
think has to happen whether we like them
or not um until Bush for whatever reason
decides to throw Iran into the axis of
Evil and that we on a road to normal SE
with Iran in the 1990s we do in the wait
what that we're on a road to normal SE
with Iran in the 1990s understanding is
that yeah from the late 90s and prior to
the Access of Evil uh labeling of Iran
that there was going to be some path
forward to where we could start to
normalize relationships with them I I I
find that very difficult to believe and
I don't see a lot of evidence I mean we
can just disagree on that okay yeah sure
we can disagree on that but I know that
once the after effects just quick note
the after effect of the Iraq war that
was the most devastating was the
increase in power of Iran I agree yeah
because of the destabilization of Iraq
and Iraq not having a uh a government
there that was functional for at least a
decade and was in fact Sunni government
right originally it was Sunni government
disbanding the the Sunni Army was one of
the worst things that the bush adist all
the former part yeah all horrible under
Republican president um but disagree
that the uh yeah that that probably
contributed more to Isis uh to the
growth of power in Iran maybe even to
the decivilization of Syria probably
more than anything that Obama did um
also the uh when we look at Iran funding
people in the region I don't disagree
with that as well I think Iran is the
number one instigator of bad guy things
right now in the Middle East Iran um the
irgc I supported when Donald Trump
killed sanii I think that was a great
thing um I I think that Iran is a major
problem however I don't know if the path
forward is constantly being a
belligerent to Iran or trying to figure
out some road to normaly I don't know if
the collapse of Iran um or the
destruction of that country considering
how unpopular the AOL even is there like
the citizens of Iran I don't think are
big supporters of the government there
um I I feel like moving on a path where
you know let's do our nuclear
inspections we had that um Iranian
nuclear deal that Trump pulled out of
let's do the nuclear inspections make
sure you're not on the way to nuclear
weapons let's unfree some funds let's
move in some Direction Where We Get on a
good term with you I feel like that's
the most important thing that needs to
happen in the Middle East as much as
people like to look at the Abraham
Accords who cares if what was it uh
Bahrain I think Oman um I think the UAE
and Morocco yeah AR like all of these
people even Saudi Arabia already have
like de facto normalization with Israel
anyway they're all trading I mean to to
pretend that that anybody even 15 years
ago would have been talking about
normalization between Saudi Arabia and
Israel is insane they already they were
already on that path they they had
already been tra they were already de
facto trading partners with each other
that that they had already been
collaborating and a wild claim that that
Israel and Saudi Arabia were going to
normalize 15 years ago 15 years ago
might have been a wild clim but after
Turkey um after Jordan and then in the
past like 20 years of like economic
relations and ties with each other all
of the leadership in the Middle East and
you'll agree with this look at Israel
and they go okay well we got
Palestinians who you know God bless them
do nothing and then you've got Israel
which is on a on a region with no
natural res ources to somehow become
like an economic giant they're good to
trade with their population is educated
they you know have military power um all
of the leadership in these Middle
Eastern countries are wanting to be
friendly with Israel and are engaging in
trade de facto with Israel and the idea
that like the UAE and bahin were brought
in to say like oh well now we're going
to officially say this I I I just those
those are the first steps toward
obviously the formation of a new Middle
East in which economics would
predominate over sectarian conflict the
chief obstacle to that is Iran the
notion that you that that negotiations
with the ayatolla were going to be a
solution to any of this is absolutely
are the is it the Abraham Accords that's
convincing Saudi Arabia to take a stance
against Iran no I mean already yeah
they're already fighting with each other
right like I don't think the Abraham ofs
moved us any closer towards any type of
real peace in the what has to happen is
something has to happen with Iran there
has to be some diplomatic bilateral
communication there no what has to
happen is the containment of Iran which
was what was in which was what was
taking place with the increased
normalization with the Sunni Arab world
and is combined with significant
economic
sanctions the notion that that there's
this farfetched notion in in foreign
policy circles that diplomacy can sort
of be wish cast out of thin air that if
you sit around a table that you can
always come to an agreement with
somebody the ayatolla do not have common
interests with the United States they do
not and this idea that they are willing
to take money in exchange for for
example some sort of PE peaceful
acquiescence to Israel's existence is
obviously untrue historically hasn't
that been the case though that you've
had a region with tons of searan
violence for a long time and then
finally turkey was like you know what
this isn't worth it the United States
paid him a lot of money they had
conversations with Israel you know what
the the economy the economic gain same
with Jordan same with into Turkish
politics but but but the the situation
with turkey was actually quite warm
between Israel and Turkey in the 90s
when you had the the you know sort of
secular Muslim
regime Turk in place and and now erdogan
is has joined in the frey erdogan is
significantly more radical than I'm so
sorry um if I said turkey I'm in Egypt
my bad yeah Egypt right so yeah so terms
of like Egypt and Jordan right were the
first two you need so you here's the
thing you need is it possible that you
could theoretically come to a deal with
Iran only with a new leadership crew
okay this is true for every peace
agreement in the region you you could
not Israel could not have made peace
with well they made peace with Egypt and
Sadat was the leader for Yom kapor right
he did not make peace with Naser right
the point is that this is a different
regime you need a different regime the
same regime that did the part of the Yum
kapore war was the same regime that
negotiated peace with Israel I mean
that's true it is also true that that is
a relationship that could be cultivated
specifically because it was Sadat who
made clear he was going to come to the
table have the Iranians ever made clear
that they would come to the table over
for example the existence of the state
of Israel uh no that is not a thing
that's going to happen but I think every
every single one of their proxy group
every one of them not only calls for the
destruction of the state of Israel they
also call for the destruction of America
I mean this is literally the houthi
slogan they're busy hitting ships and
their slogan is literally ALU Akbar
death to America death to the Jews death
to Israel doesn't fit on a bumper
sticker but that and it's not all that
catchy but that is in fact their slogan
the notion that the regime that
propagates that is going to be approach
with diplomacy is not only wrong the
problem is that we it's easy to say the
stakes of diplomacy are okay so we try
to talk right jaw jaw is better than war
war sure the only problem is that in the
Middle East weakness is taken as a sign
that aggression might be an appropriate
response that is how things work in the
Middle East and the fact that Barack
that that Joe Biden rather came into
office with an orientation toward
continuing the Biden the Obama policies
in Iran has led to conflagrations these
sort of brush fires breaking out
everywhere that Iran has borders with
either the west or Israel or both right
any place that's happening it's leading
to brushfires because again the logic of
violence in the Middle East is quite the
logic of violence in other places in the
world by the way I think the logic of
violence in the m is actually closer to
what most International politics looks
like than we than we wish that it were I
mean I think that's part of what's
happening in Ukraine as well which
brings me by the way here's my question
about Ukraine just real quick you so you
think that for Iran right a country that
has been sanctioned for God knows how
many years now you think that for Iran
just continuing to sanction them and
contain them is an effective way is more
effective than trying to engage them in
bilateral or multilateral peace talks
yes 100% okay and the proof is in the
pudding before we go to Ukraine can I
ask about Israel so you're both mostly
in agreement but what is I don't know if
i' say that okay but as I'm learning uh
what is Israel doing right what is
Israel doing wrong in this very specific
current war in
Gaza um I mean frankly I think that what
Israel is doing wrong is if I were
Israel okay like again America's
interests are not coincident with
Israel's interests if if if I were an
Israeli leader I would swiveled up and
out would and knocked the leap out ofah
early what do does mean so I I would
have I would y Galant who was the
defense minister of Israel was
encouraging netanyahu's the Prime
Minister and the war cabinet including
Benny Gan so whenever people talk about
the Netanyahu government that's not
what's in place right now there's a
Unity War government in place that
includes the political opposition the
reason I point that out is because there
are a lot of people politically who will
suggest that the actions Israel is
currently taking are somehow the
manifestation of a right-wing government
Israel currently does not have a
quotequote right-wing government they
have Unity government that includes the
opposition in any case y Galant was
urging in the very early days of the war
that Israel should turn north and
instead of hitting Hamas they should
actually take the opportunity to knock
hisbah out because hisbah is
significantly more dangerous to the
existence of the state of Israel than
Hamas I actually agree with that uh as
far as what Israel has been doing wrong
in the actual War I mean I think
that again from an American perspective
I think that Israel is is doing pretty
well from an Israeli perspective V
Israeli I would actually want Israel to
be less loose about sending its soldiers
in on the ground level so Israel's
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties and the cost of that has been
the highest military death toll that
Israel has had since the 1973 yum kipur
War I mean I personally know through one
degree of separation three separate
people have been killed in Gaza and
that's because they're going in door
Todo it's because they're they're
attempting to minimize civilian
casualties and they're losing a lot of
guys in in this particular in this
particular War um you know the the the
problem that Israel has had historically
speaking is that Israel got very
complacent about its own security
situation they beli the technology was
going to somehow correct for the hatred
on the other side of the wall that very
okay so our people have to live
underground for two weeks at a time
while some Rockets fall but at least
it's not a war and that complacence you
know bred what happened on October 7th
so to to me what Israel did wrong was
years and years and years of complacence
and belief in an Oso system that is at
root a failure because you cannot make a
peace agreement with people who do not
want make peace with you so that that
that's what I think Israel is doing
wrong I I have a feeling there's going
to be wide Divergence on this point um
maybe uh so uh in terms of broadly
speaking um I generally oppose
settlement expansion is a thing that
Israel does incorrectly that I think is
kind of like provocative to at least all
the Palestinians uh in the West Bank and
I probably energizes hatred in the Gaza
STP for them as well in terms of
conducting uh in terms of conducting
Warfare uh the one thing that I always
say to everybody uh especially Americans
is you can't evaluate things from an
American perspective it's very stupid
happened a lot with Ukraine where people
like oh well didn't they work with the
Nazis and like weren't the Soviets the
good guys and it's like well in in other
parts of the world it's not quite as
simple um and I think the same is true
for Israel Palestine that a lot of
Americans will analyze the conflict as
just being one between only Israel and
Palestine which is not it's a conf
between Israel and then Palestine
Hezbollah the houthis and Iran right now
it is um I think that the however one
area where I'll break with Ben is is I
think that minimizing civilian
casualties and everything is very very
very important I think on the Israeli
side I don't think it's important so
that the US will stay with them because
I think the US is probably going to
stick with Israel as long as they don't
do anything crazy and I don't even think
it matters for the International
Community it doesn't definitely doesn't
matter for the UN because Jesus Christ
um however I think it's really really
really important that I think that in
the Middle East broadly speaking I think
that leadership especially in the Gulf
has gotten over the Palestinian uh issue
I think that leadership is kind of like
they don't care as much anymore but the
populations still care quite a bit and I
think that the main issue that Israel
could run into is if the civilian death
toll does climb too high and if they
start to hit this you know 40 50 60,000
number of Civilian casualties they run
the risk of the civilian populations and
the surrounding middle eastern states
becoming so antagonistic towards Israel
that they start to take steps back
towards normalization in the region so
for instance I know that um Bahrain I
think already pulled out their
Ambassador um to Israel my guess is
going to be it's temporary um I know
that on the um on the public speaking
side you've got a lot of people
condemning Israel for the attacks and on
the private side you've got people
telling Israel please kill all of Hamas
because this is untenable and nobody
wants to work in the situation um I
don't know if this ended up being true
or not I'm guessing it didn't but I saw
on a couple of Twitter accounts it was
leaked that potentially Saudi Arabia was
considering installing a government in
the West Bank that they would run um no
I mean I I think Israel would love
nothing better than that but that is not
one of the big problems in the Middle
East is literally no one wants to
preside over the Palestinians no one
Arab states Israel no one so I think the
issue is and I think and I'm largely
actually I'm very sympathetic towards
the Palestinians because I think that
for um since 48 and onwards I think that
all of the Arab states super gassed them
up on that they wanted the Palestinians
to fight because they wanted to fight
with Israel um however as time has gone
on and theyve realized that the it's
kind of a lost cause states have started
to drop out so you're getting these
bilateral uh peace treaties with um
Egypt and with Jordan you're getting
multilateral agreements like the Abraham
Accords and now the Palestinians are
looking around like okay well you guys
told us to fight all this time and now
the only people that we have supporting
us are Iranian proxies um so the
Palestinians are in a very weird spot
where they've like lost all their
support um yeah I think that I think
that Israel what I would say to be quote
unquote critical of Israel is Israel
needs to take strong steps towards peace
that probably involves them enduring
some undue hardship so not the October
7th attacks because Jesus that's way too
much but you know other types of you
know attacks that they might have to
deal with that might cause some
civilians to die that they don't come
out over the top with and and retaliate
with if there's ever going to be peace
in that region however another thing
that I've always said is a huge problem
between Israel and Palestine is I think
that both sides think that if they
continue to fight it will be good for
them but the problem is one side is
delusional uh Israel I think Israel
wants to continue to fight because they
get justifications for uh the annexation
of the Golan Heights they get
justifications for expansions especially
in area C that I that think they're
probably going to try to Annex soon uh
they get justifications for the
increased military posturing uh towards
the Gaza Strip and the embargos and
Israel is right that if the conflict
continues really the situation only
improves for Israel Over time but the
Palestinians also all believe that if
they keep fighting they thought this
since 2000 under Arafat that if they
just keep fighting they'll get better
gains too but that's not the case is
there a difference between Palestinian
citizens and the leadership when you say
that I love all people I love all people
around the world and I think that when
we analyze issues I think that we have
to be very honest with what the people
on the ground think and the idea that
Hamas is just this one-off thing in the
Gaza Strip is not only incorrect with
the situation on the ground it's also
incredibly ahistorical um and the idea
that like the Palestinians in the West
Bank of which I believe the most recent
polling shows I want to say 75 to 80%
support the October 7th attacks um
Palestinians in general want to fight in
violent conflict with Israel that's not
just the position of the government
that's not just people there's a reason
why a boss doesn't want to do uh
elections in the West Bank uh and it's
because the Palestinian people really do
want fight with Israel but to combat
that problem is like you have to get the
UN on board we've got to do an actual
addressing of the Palestinian refugee
problem which is handled like a joke
right now um Iran has to be brought to
the table in terms of negotiations uh
there has to be huge efforts made to
economically Revitalize these like
Palestinian areas even though they're
one of the highest recipients of Aid in
the world um you you have to do
something about the Embargo and the
blockade in the Gaza Strip which isn't
just maintained by Israel it's also
maintained by Egypt you should ask why
um yeah there's a lot of things that
have to happen to fix that problem but
the reality is is I don't think Israel
really wants to because they get to
continue their expansion into the West
Bank and I don't think anybody around
the world really cares that much mon we
won't be talking I will argue with that
the idea that Israel does not want to
end the conflict is be lied by the
history of what just happened with the
Gaza Strip so when we talk about
settlements for example Israel did have
settlements inside the Gaza Strip there
were 8,000 Jews who were living inside
the Gaza Strip in gush katif uh up until
2005 they they they withdrew all of
those people I mean took them literally
out of their homes uh and the result was
not the burgeoning of a of a better
attitude toward the state of Israel with
regard to for example you know the the
Palestinian population in Gaza in fact
it was more radical in Gaza than it was
in the West Bank uh the the the result
was obviously the election of Hamas the
the October 7th attacks in which
unfortunately many civilians took place
took part in the October 7th attacks
there's video of people rushing who are
civilians and dressed in civilian
clothing into Israeli Villages always
the same thing well no no that is that
is 100% true obviously uh and when it
comes to you know area SE and Israel's
you know supposed deep and abiding
desire for territorial expansion in area
SE area SE so for for those who are not
familiar with the oso cords and again
this is getting very abstruse but the
oso cords are broken down into three
areas of the West Bank area a is under
full Palestinian control that' be like
Janine and ablus the the major cities
for example there's area B which is
mixed Israeli Palestinian control where
Israel provides some level of military
security and control uh and then there's
area C and area C was like to be decided
later it was left up for possible
concessions to the Palestinian Authority
if the oo Accords had moved forward
those are disputed territories there is
building taking place in areas by both
actually no one talks about this but by
by Palestinians as well as Israelis uh
and the the you know question is to
whether if Israel sto building there
have been many settlement freees in the
past including some undertaken by
Netanyahu uh and and it actually has not
done one iota of good in moving the ball
forward in terms of actual negotiations
again the the biggest problem is that
the leadership ship for Palestinians has
spent every day since really 67 it's not
even 48 because after 40 between 48 and
67 Jordan was in charge of the West Bank
in Egypt was in charge of the Gaza Strip
and in no point did either of those
Powers say hey maybe we ought to hand
this over to an independent Palestinian
state which was originally the division
that was that was promoted by the UN
partition plan in
47 because of that uh the the leadership
post 67 and really starting in ' 64 the
Palestine Liberation Organization was
founded in ' 64 and it called for the
liberation
of the land
in4 they had the West Bank and they had
the Gaza Strip so they're talking about
Tel Aviv when it was founded in in 64
the basic idea as you know kind of
indicated by that was Israel will not
exist and that was a promise that's been
made by pretty much every Palestinian
leader in Arabic to the people that they
are talking to yasat famously would do
this sort of thing he'd speak in English
and talk about how he wanted a two State
solution and then he'd go back to his
own people and say this is a trojan
horse and we're if Israel could if if
you think that Israeli parents want to
send their kids at the age of 18 to go
and monitor Janine and Nablus and be in
in kanun you're out of your mind you're
out of your mind Israelis do not want
that in fact Israelis didn't want that
so much that they allowed Rockets to
fall in their cities for full on 18
years in order to avoid sending soldiers
on mass back into the Gaza Strip true
but I think Israel does want to continue
to expand settlements into the West Bank
right they want to continue to build
they want to have Jerusalem East
Jerusalem as well well I mean East
Jerusalem has already been annexed so
East Jerusalem is according to Israel a
part of Israel that's not a settlement
sure okay so there there's that with
regard to you know does Israel have an
interest in expanding settlements in the
Westbank why would they not until
there's a peace partner sure that's what
I mean but I'm saying as long as the
conflict continues like because even
when you talk about no but your
suggestion is that they're incentivizing
the conflict to continue so they can
grab more land well no let me be very
clear I don't think there's like a PL
like so some people say for instance uh
they'll take that one quote from
Netanyahu and they'll try to say that
like he was funding the people in the
Gaza Strip by allowing kariani to come
in even though he was actually speaking
in opposition to aboss allowing the gusa
strip to fall for Netanyahu to clear it
out for him they give it back etc etc
I'm not saying I'm not claiming those
theories I'm just saying that I think
that Israel will take a relatively
neutral stance towards conflict enduring
because as long as the conflict endures
and as long as the uh settlements can
expand I think that benefits I think
that ultimately benefits Israel the I
think there would be very let's put this
way if suddenly there arose among the
Palestinians a deep and abiding desire
for peace approved by a vast majority of
the population with serious security
guarantees I think you'd be very
hardpressed to find Israelis who would
not be willing to at least consider that
in not expanding bathrooms in a FR I
kind of I would have agreed with you on
October 6th I think we're probably a
year or two away from that right now no
no but that the point I'm making is that
Israelis now realized that the entire
peace process was a sham meaning the
people who are on the other side of the
table were using it as a trojan horse in
the first place the the death of Oslo is
not the death of Israeli hopefulness
it's the death of the illusion that on
the other side of the table was anyone
worth bargaining with that's what's
happening and that's why you have this
sort of insane disconnect right now
between the United States and the
Israeli government again it's a Unity
government no one in is Israel is
talking about making concessions to the
Palestinian Authority for a wide variety
of reasons including the fact that
Mahmud abas fat continues to pay actual
families of terrorists who kill Jews the
fund right and and which is from the the
moderate West Bank right exactly that's
that so yeah again like the taste in
Israel for this is a even the people who
are the the kilon right those are the
most secular people in Israel which was
by the way the place that was attacked
on October 7th I mean what people should
understand is that October 7th was not
an attack against settlements in the
West B it was an attack on peace
Villages that were essentially disarmed
and many of these people who were killed
were peace activists who were literally
trying to work with people in Gaza to
get them J I mean it's just it's it's
mind boding that's why you've had this
ground shift in Israel the next 20 years
in Israel is going to be about security
and economic development period end of
story everything else goes second third
place and I will say I agree essentially
with everything you're saying um not to
loop back on another topic but this is
one of the reasons then why I was so
critical I don't want to say critical
but like kind of nonchalant about the
Abraham Accords because they didn't
address anything with the Palestinians
whatsoever they brought countries that
wer super relevant to the conflict they
didn't bring in Qatar which is where a
lot of the money and support for the god
con they didn't involve Iran at all they
involved bilateral no but it totally
changed the mentality and this is why
what I'm seeing right now this is why
listen I think that that Biden has done
better than I certainly expected him to
do in terms of support for Israel like
Obama was way less supportive of Israel
Biden by every metric with that said the
rhetoric that he's been using recently
and the blankin have been using recently
about Israel needs to make painful
concessions for peace Israel recentering
this issue at the center of relations in
the Middle East is doomed to failure the
magic
magic is a strong word the the benefit
of the Abraham Accords was proof of what
you're saying which is true which is
that all the surrounding countries in
reality have abandoned the idea that
there is a centrality to the
palestinian-israeli conflict that is not
the central conflict in the Middle East
and by the way one of the reasons not
is because actually ironically because
of the rise of Iran right it's it's
Sunni states that are largely signing up
with Israel because they're realizing
they need some sort of counterweight to
a a burgeoning nuclear power in
Iran can we talk about Ukraine sure you
have a disagreement with you uh with
with what uh Destiny said my my main
problem with Biden's policy with regard
to Ukraine is that he outsourced the end
goal of the war to zalinsky early on now
that might make sense if that goal were
something that he was willing to fund to
the point of achievement uh or if zinski
could have achieved it on his own but
right now and this has been true since
pretty early on in the war this point
Henry Kissinger made uh this that that
pretty early on in the war was very
clear that for
example Crimea was going nowhere the
Russians had control of Crimea barring
the United States giving permission to
fly f-16s over Crimea nothing was going
to change over there the same thing was
true in most of the donbas right in
luhansk and DK that that was not going
to change zinsky stated goal and you
understand it he's the leader of Ukraine
right is is that there was a predation
on his territory in 2014 and that the
Russians sent their little green men
across the border and then they took all
of these areas and so he as the leader
of Ukraine is saying okay I want all of
that back now the reality is that the
US's interest had largely been achieved
in the first few months of the war
meaning the revocation of the ability of
Russia to take Ukraine and just ingest
it and two the devastation of of
Russia's military capability I mean
Russia has just been wrecked I mean
their military is in serious Straits
because of the war in Ukraine from an
American perspective I'm very much Pro
all of that I think that we have an
interest in Ukraine maintaining a buffer
status against territorially aggressive
Russia I think that the United States
does have an interest in degrading the
Russian milit to the extent that it
can't threaten the Baltic states or
threaten Kazakhstan or other countries
in the region the problem I have with
Biden's strategy is as always I think
that it's a muddle and I think muddles
tend to end with misperceptions war
tends to break out and maintain because
of misperception misperception of the
other side's strength the other side's
intentions and and all of the rest
people misperceive what's going to
happen they say I I'll cross that line
and nothing will happen right this is
what Putin thought he thought I'll cross
that line they'll greet me as a
liberator and because the United States
just surrendered in Afghan essentially
they won't do anything and the West is
fragmenting because NATO's fragmenting
and all the rest of this and obviously
he was wrong on on all those scores the
problem for for Biden is that as with
virtually every war no end line was set
and so it became out recently that was
widely reported that actually there was
a peace deal that was on the table in
the first few months that Putin was on
board with uh that basically would have
seeded luhansk and detet and crimeia to
Russia in return for solidification of
those lines American and Western
Security guarantees to Ukraine right
Ukraine wouldn't formally join NATO but
there would be security guarantees to
Ukraine we're ending up there anyway
it's just taking a lot more money and a
lot more time to get there and do you
think Trump would have helped push that
piece yes and I think and I think that
Biden actually did zilinsky a bit of a
disservice because zinski knows where
this war is going to end and it's not
going to end with lanskin denes and
Crimea in Ukrainian hands it's just not
going to and he knows that what actually
in my opinion zalinski needed was for
Joe Biden to be the person who foisted
that deal upon him so that he could then
go back to his own people and say listen
guys I wanted all those things but the
Americans weren't willing to allow me to
have all those things and so we did an
amazing job we did a heroic job in
defending our own land we devastated the
Russian military even though no one
expected us to but we can't get back
those things because it's unrealistic to
get back to those things because America
basically they're big funer and they're
the ones who want the deal instead what
Biden said and this was reported in the
Washington Post last year the Biden
Administration said we're going to fight
for as long as it takes with as much as
it takes and when they were asked until
when they said whatever zalinsky says
and that's not a policy that's just a
recipe for a frozen conflict with
endless funding now it may be that Putin
has walked away from the table and that
deal is no longer available if that deal
is is available right now I certainly
hope that's being pursued behind closed
doors my main critique again of Biden is
that when you Outsource the end goal to
another country without stating what
America's interest is that's a problem I
also think that Biden did really quite a
poor job of sort of explaining what
America's realistic interest are I I I
don't like it when American leaders um
it's weird for me to say this but I'm
not a huge fan of the we're in it to
protect democracy kind of rhetoric
because frankly we are allied with many
many countries that are not democracies
and that's not actually how foreign
policy Works uh we should as an overall
you know 30,000 foot goal Advanced
democracy and and rights where we can
but the reason that we were
fighting in favor of Ukraine and when I
say fighting I mean giving them money
and giving them Weaponry the reason we
were doing that in favor of Ukraine is
not because of Ukraine's long history of
clean voting and non-c Corruption the
reason that we were doing that is to
counter Russian interests in the region
I mean that was it was a pure real
politic play and that real politic play
is hard to deny no matter what side of
the aisle you're on I think that what
many Americans are going to are
reverting to is we have no interest
there why are we spending the money
there and not spending the money here
and that that kind of stuff and that
that argument can always be applied
unless you actually articulate the
reason why it is good for Americans
Beyond simply the ideological for the
United States to be involved in a thing
so for example I think right now when
when Biden is talk I think that what
Biden just did he's the United States as
we speak is striking the houthis I think
that that's a really really good thing I
think that's a necessary thing I think
American people should understand why
that is happening it's not because of
quote unquote ideology it is I mean on a
on a very root level but really it's
because you're you're screwing up the
Straits I mean you can't you can't do
that you can't screw up free trade and
Americans have an interest in not seeing
all of our prices at the grocery store
double and triple because a bunch of rag
tag Pirates
you know akin to the the barber pirates
from 1800 are are bothering everyone
right so Ben said a lot there do you
disagree with any aspect on the Ukraine
side um a little bit yeah um I think on
the macro I agree maybe we get into we a
little bit on some things I on the final
thing that he said though I wish that
Americans could have honest
conversations about foreign policy I
think that it would just be better for
everybody um I don't know if it's uh you
know Red Scare after the Cold War where
it was like literally you know the
behemoths you know were fighting against
communism and we felt like after 91
every single foreign policy decision
needs to be able to be explained in like
seven words like he's the bad guy and
that's it um I wish we had more honest
conversations about uh what our foreign
policy interest is in a particular
region because I don't think most
Americans honestly could even articulate
why Israel would be an important Ally or
why it's important to defend Ukraine
against Russia or why should we care
about Taiwan at all I don't know if most
Americans could articulate anything
there um even though they might have
very strong opinions about why we ought
to be involved in certain conflicts so
do agree with that I wish we had more
honest conversations about uh foreign
policy um in terms of how Biden has
handled Ukraine the things that I liked
the most were one that he was very clear
in the beginning about what we wouldn't
do so Biden saying that we're not going
to do um uh not a Redline no fly zones
over Ukraine we're not going to be
deploying troops on the ground in
Ukraine we're not going to be doing
anything that would have you know US
soldiers and Russian soldiers crossing
swords with each other that's not going
to happen I like that he made that very
clear at the beginning um and I like
that he Coalition built between NATO and
the EU to get people to send uh funds
training soldiers airplanes and
everything to Ukraine I thought those
two things were really good in terms of
basically writing zalinsky blank check I
would like to hope that Biden and the
entire United States learned a lesson
from Iraq and Afghanistan that
open-ended missions with unlimited
budgets and no clear goal are like the
worst foreign policy decisions you can
ever do they've like defined US foreign
policy for the past two or three decades
which is unfortunate but seems to be the
case um
my my feeling would be and this is just
a feeling I don't know if internal
cables have leaked that say otherwise is
the uh the Biden Administration has
probably always had a quiet position of
at some point there's going to be an
off-ramp here and I think even a month
or two ago I think those talks were
being leaked that discussion had begun
with zalinsky looking for an off-ramp
but publicly of course the United States
is never going to come out and say we're
going to support you guys to fight as
much as you want for three months and
then after that it's no more obviously
that can't be the statement it's always
going to be that we're going to support
you in your fight against Russia we
tried that under Obama with Afghanistan
it was terrible yeah you can't escalate
The Troop levels to X but only for six
months and then we yeah you can't you
just can't do that it's always going to
come off as we're going to support you
forever and as long as it takes and as
long as you need whatever we have to do
to defend freedom and democracy in your
country and any any other statement
would be absurd so I can understand why
it feels like on a public level a blank
check and an indefinite time period was
granted to zinski but I don't think
that's going to be the case I think I
again I hope we've learned our lessons
in the Middle East about the Forever War
that this isn't going to be a forever
funding to Ukraine to fight for as long
as they want um I do disagree I feel
like we're playing a little bit
retrospectively saying that like well
it's obvious that they're not going to
capture the Don boss it's obvious that
they're not going to capture Crimea I
agree for Crimea that was incredibly
obvious but it was also really obvious
that in two weeks Russia would own Kev
and Ukraine was going to be Belarus 2.0
I think that even for a lot of uh
military people um and analysts around
the world uh that that that was an
expectation or at least a significant
probability nobody knew uh the phrase
It's thr around now as paper tiger that
Russia's military was as ill equipped as
they were so I can understand why
especially if you're Ukraine and if
you've repelled an invasion from one of
the world's largest armies why you might
feel like well it you know let's
fight for a few months let's fight for a
year let's see what happens and I can
understand the United States supporting
them but I agree that there has to be
some reasonable offramp but we're not
going to fight forever I think the US um
state department has already begun those
conversations with zinsky to look at
what that offramp looks like um but yeah
I'm not too sure other than like
explicitly stating publicly like you can
only fight until this date I don't
really know what else I would change I
don't think I don't think the Biden
Administration should have done that I I
don't know what else do you think Biden
should cut this deal on uh on the
funding meaning there's like six there's
this $105 billion deal that's been held
up by debate between Republicans and
Democrats over border right so basically
it contains $60 billion for Ukraine 14
billion for Israel another several
billion dollars for taiwan's defense
against China and then includes some
border funding and some border
Provisions Republicans want the Border
funding and the Border Provisions
because we can get into the illegal
immigration issue but that's pretty
serious issue and Biden Democrats have
been unwilling to hold that up and that
that seems to me like just from put
aside Republican Democrat seems like
political malpractice meaning there's a
widespread perception in the United
States that the border is a disaster
area Joe Biden wants these things many
Republicans don't want these things if
he caves On the Border stuff he gets all
the things that he wants and he's going
to be able to go back to the moderates
in the country and say I did something
about the Border it seems like such an
obvious win if he caves On the Border
stuff even on the Ukraine stuff yes
because then he gets the whole package
meaning he can he can go back to his own
base and he can say listen guys I wanted
to I wanted be easy on the border the
Republicans forced me to it but we
needed the Ukraine Aid we needed the
Taiwan right that's you're honestly
you're going to be more educated than me
on this I don't like uh or maybe maybe I
just don't know enough I don't like the
principle that when we negotiate things
in the United States there's like 50
million hostages at all points in time
for every single thing like oh boy here
comes the debt ceiling what do the
Republicans want what do the Democrats
want oh boy like here you know we can't
fund our government um but I mean
obviously the the argument is going to
be that if the Ukraine funding doesn't
come in this bill and if and his
administration feel like it's really
important that un or not unilaterally
but as a single issue it's not going to
pass so um I would say that at this
point and I don't know what the
conversations look like between the bid
Administration and zinsky I would say at
this point that it's probably fair to
start making contingencies on the money
that we give to Ukraine that listen like
this uh conflict has you know waged on
now like now we need to start looking
for potential peace we can't just write
you an unlimited check so I mean if
those strings are attached I'd be okay
with it but the broader question of like
is it okay to make this particular piece
of legislation with all this funding
conent on uh Ukrainian funding I mean
that just seems to be the way the
government works now
unfortunately